they will end the game George Picken is
the real deal and this is coming from a
Bengals fan so if I'm telling you he's a
real deal he's getting well over well
over 750. that's disrespectful all right
I can go I can go out there right now
and get 750. yeah at 55 years old where
Kenny Pickens as your quarterback yeah
my grandma could come quarterback
okay all right Garrett Wilson over under
eight and a half touchdowns over
absolutely over now he's got Aaron
Rodgers
at all but whoa whoa whoa rewind and
come back today's Sunday yeah today's
Sunday it is and the devil's at work for
you not to like Aaron Rodgers no he
doesn't like him I actually don't it's
not that I don't like him it's mostly
that I hate him I don't want anything to
do with Aaron Rodgers that's not nice no
I know it's not nice you should repent
nah I'm good when you come to Chicago
and say you know somebody's City well
technically statistically speaking out
of 30 Games he's 25 and five if I'm not
mistaken yeah it's fine I know the
number that is ownership I told you no
what's the next one Jamar Chase over
under 10 touchdowns this season that's a
good one
I'm over yeah yeah it looks that looks
like a good one to me I mean I think the
comfortability now that Joe has he's got
his money jamar's locked in I think
they're gonna have a big year like you
said matter of fact you know what he's
definitely going to be over because he
needs to be over so they can pay him his
money too right because he's up next
absolutely up next all right Tyrique
Hill over under 1300 and a half
receiving him over
for 2K dude Tyrique might be at 1300 by
week 10.
statistically that would be under
understand this is Tyree impossible it's
that's not happening it was 10. he's
impossible to cover he's very possible
to cover he's very not about being fast
they put him in positions to make sure
he creates mismatches so he will
get 1300 over Chad how many times have
you you've done this what three three
times three or four times in your career
over 1300 yards maybe five it's not that
easy though well I didn't make it easy
because I was talking so much so I
made it much more difficult but Tyrique
he walks in quietly we know he's fast
he's going to get it he did say he was
going for 2K I don't know okay and if he
and if he goes for 2K and falls short
it'll probably be what 17 1800 so you
definitely go to over yeah I like the
over as well all right and last but
certainly not least Justin Jefferson
over or under 1400 and a half yards
absolutely over you know why it's over
why because he wants his money and he's
going to get it he's going to get his
money he's a gritty all the way to the
bank
the right person to set the market Ryan
you got to take on that's the third best
wide receiver in the league ah
there we go yeah there might be maybe
four
who's three Chad Jamar Chase
okay all right Chase maybe all right so
everyone that's in the chat drop your
takes drop your Best Bets cause we got
our man chat Ocho Cinco and now he's
gonna grade our Best Bets of the day
Ryan do you want I'll go first all right
I'll go first mine's very simple I've I
made a mention of it earlier I'm putting
within my means right
a stupid amount of money on DJ Moore to
score a touchdown today and in Soldier
Field that's not dumb not dumb no what
would you give that letter grade eight
throughout that's an a let's go that's a
that's what it's about DJ Moore
DJ Moore Justin field connection is
going to be crazy as soldier field
throughout the season throughout the
season not just not just not just today
no not just one plus two equals six baby
let's go if I give that nay too I love
the Bears today let's go all right Ryan
floor is yours what's your best bet and
then you gotta grade his bet so Chad
what they call me on the show they the
king of the best bet okay last year is
ten and three that's unheard of right
it's like almost never wrong like you
you're never wrong right today
it's all about the Cleveland Browns dude
the Cleveland Browns plus two and a half
it is they they are coming back this
year with a Vengeance I'm not saying
they're gonna win the AFC North but this
is a moment for them so you have the
Browns day two and a half yes see this
is the great thing about life
this is the great thing about life in
life
we all have flaws
right thank you I have questions and
today you were you you you are showing
and telling us where your flaw is
which is what not being realistic
this is similar to a woman that goes on
day after date and it is a hopeless
romantic
the fairy tale did you hear the record
listening plus two and a half a d d a d
i I would have given him an F there's no
way I may give him a d and just I'm
giving him a d because I love him I love
him and we all have we can all be wrong
in life
thank you Matt I love you too listen the
thing is that in certain circumstances
that's passing I'll take a d
that's passing I didn't fail the course
you know what I mean that's a good one
Ryan do we have do we have Chad open do
we have any pics from the chat we can go
in and look while we do that
let me get your take on dolphins
Chargers today dolphin charges listen um
Mike Williams good Justin Herbert great
Keenan Allen
are you not worried about the Chargers
coaching no I'm not working
I never ever go towards a coaching
because that's not their job as a coach
the players have to play the players
have to execute no matter what the exit
knows the best players to execute
can tour stay healthy
I hope so a Dolphin fan at heart
obviously I'm from Miami I'm from
Liberty City right Born raised all my
life I want to stay healthy if Tula can
stay upright run a game there's no
weakness offensively so you think
obviously I'm not sure what's going to
happen
but so you think Dolphins over Chargers
today yeah yeah how about uh if he's
healthy all he has to do is facilitate
how about uh Cowboys Giants oh Sunday
night that's a good one who you got it's
in it's in Jersey the Cowboys fan yeah
it is in Jersey it's not your York thank
you for saying that I don't got anything
to say about New York anyway yeah
that's a tough one Dak Prescott owns the
Giants you want to talk about ownership
10-0 in this last 10. 10-0 in his last
10. but they just paid Danny dimes I
know they did they just they just paid
Danny dimes overpaid if we're being
honest
that's somebody else's pocket not mine
yeah so who do you think who do you like
Cowboys or Giants tonight
that's tough
come on chat you're never wrong come on
I'm never wrong but sometimes I know
when to bow out when I don't know you
leaving it yeah okay I'm leaving it I
got something from the chat okay uh
Cowboys by the way but they're all good
um Rob Dog
Odell Beckham anytime touchdown for the
Ravens
I mean he's back he's healthy
I think he's going to really be I think
he gets one today I'm not sure I'm not
sure where it won't be what we're used
to seeing him taking a slant route and
going 80 yards right but I think in the
Red Zone yeah I think he has a
possibility you know and he won't be in
a slot much
and I think they probably leave Zay
flowers one-on-one for some reason I
just I just I can feel it
I'm not sure may I I think so okay Ricky
locks says Eagles minus three and a half
against the Patriots today
for some reason I have a feeling the
Eagles should build them out the Eagles
oh wow
Eagles blow out yeah I have a feeling
yeah and there's no disrespect I know
they have Bill you know the genius
Belichick the Eagles are going to make a
state this is going to be a statement
game I will also say I can feel it I'm
on the Patriots today plus three and a
half
um
Bill Belichick's coming off a breakup
and he might be he might go score third
yeah so Belichick may go take the ball
himself and do what he needs to do you
know what I mean sometimes you listen to
Taylor Swift sometimes you listen to Lil
Wayne Right Bill Belichick's coming out
there and he's smoking on that Eagles
pack yeah he is I don't I don't think so
no I don't think so all right I'm not a
Nick siriano guy I can't I can't do it
it ain't even about Nick it's just a
better understanding of the Eagles
offensively it's like that's it's almost
unfair but think about that offensive
line defense the defense defensive
they're not sad they are not that's not
like you play Madden yeah of course
that's basically an ultimate team in
real life yeah yeah they got a
defensively and offensively I don't
understand how they fit everybody under
the salary cap unfair and then the last
one Bill's Jets Monday Night Football
Jets Jets Jets as much as I love I love
I love Stefan Diggs and Josh Allen but
Jets you know I think you just get the
momentum of the season rolling and the
turnaround of the just organization and
team they're winning okay bowling are
you on the Jets I'm not on the Jets come
on come on dude I'm taking the bills
absolutely you know who plays
quarterback for the Jets that bad man
that bad man dude why would I ever bet
on him he's a bag
all right my Grandma will come down and
hit me in the head if I put a bet on
Aaron Rodgers but what if you win money
I don't care buy your grandma something
nice I don't care
all right
we're coming up to the end we got a big
game here in Chicago today
we're gonna need your pick I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get uh Ryan's pick first
what do you like today Bears Packers 325
at Soldier Field dude I am really all
over the Bears money line I know you
know we got a squad here today who's all
over the Packers I'm not gonna call them
chalk eaters that would be rude and I
have to spend that entire day with these
guys so I won't do that
um but the public is all over the
Packers I just don't understand it
Christian Watson's out Romeo Dobbs is
possible yeah exactly and I don't know
this Bear's team is Hungry Like Jordan
love did that whole thing on Father's
Day where he you know called Bears fans
his father by accident he was tripping
yeah I think he did he didn't execute it
the plane didn't land the way he wanted
it to no no not again yeah I don't know
stick to football for him but
um yeah I love the Bears I think the
city is going to remember that I think
the Bears are going to remember that and
I think this is the day they turn the
page so I'm on the Bears all right well
quickly I mean it's pretty obvious all
great things come from Chicago
I agree I agree on a lot of your takes I
think this is the day where we do change
the narrative
new GM rhyme poles came in said we're
going to take the North and never give
it back that might be a little
aggressive
but we're catching the Packers at a
really good time they're hobbled and I
don't want anybody to care about any of
that go in there and beat their ass
Bears minus six today
alternate spread we don't just want to
win we want to make a statement I'm on
the Bears Chad
Bears Packers take it away listen I had
the Bears today if you are a betting man
or betting woman or betting other
whatever that may be however you
identify Bears money line the Packers
are hobbled unfortunately
and take it you know what it is let's go
listen to it let's go I'm never wrong
I'm never wrong the GM said we're taking
it let me see that Ryan yeah let me see
this throw it
oh my bad
let's go
you heard it here first
I'm never wrong and he's never wrong
never wrong and he's giving out refunds
but you're not getting refunded on the
Bears game because they don't have to
absolutely winning winning tonight 100
percent
Chad
I was worried I was worried I didn't
want I didn't want to have to sit here
and be upset with you if you picked the
Packers but no my main man 100 Grand
yeah we're gonna win some money today
Ryan any final thoughts no man this was
fun Chad we got some locks some
questionable picks from you I will ride
nothing nothing I said was questionable
no I I know that's what you're saying
but you know I we might be on we might
two and a half dude Brown's two and a
half remember you're gonna remember this
what are we doing you're gonna remember
this dude what are we doing and Pat's
plus three and a half don't
what that's three and a half Brown
quarterback you might want to Parlay
that who's a quarterback Matt yeah
listen I'm not a master who's the
quarterback for the pets not a Mac Jones
guy I'm not a Mac Jones I'm a Bill
Belichick guy
coming off the breakup man come on he
won he's like you're thinking you're
thinking with your heart not your mind
dude I don't like the packs I'm not a
past guy you are a hopeless romantic for
certain I am honestly Browns yeah all
right well thank you everyone who tapped
in with us I love you guys call me Chad
for coming pulling up to the shop I'm
here next week
that sounds good I know Chad make it
happen I know you had a chance to talk
to some Chicago fans some football fans
and put together Chicago parlay for me
I'm Michael bowling for producer Ryan
three-time All-Pro six times FIFA Legend
Zone Legend
all that good stuff if you need me feel
free to call me
786-235-5412 do not edit this save the
number I'm here for you if you need
anything in life reach out it's a good
man to know let's take a look at that
Chicago parlay and hope everybody cashes
their bets it's Christmas day baby it is
let's go let's do it man
what's up man social I'm here with my
guy Greg and I'm trying to do repairs
probably for today I need your pick all
day every day it's Bear's money line man
I'm gonna take Justin Fields over
rushing yards how sure is he if he's the
Steeler fans
who must crave anytime touchdown scorer
rookie tight end they're gonna be
leaning on him you need a little safety
valve no Christian Watson I think that's
just getting in the end zone first
what's up manisocho I'm here with my guy
Greg and I'm trying to do a bear's
parlay for today
all day every day it's Bear's money line
man I'm gonna take Justin Fields over
rushing yards how sure is he
if you think about that
let's crave anytime touchdowns score
they're gonna be leaning on him you need
a little safety valve no Christian
Watson I think that's just getting the
end zone first what's up manasso I'm
here with my guy Greg and I'm trying to
do a bears probably for today I need you
foreign
[Music]